Das wovor. Alle immer gewarnt hatten ist jetzt im kongo passiert und es erinnert sehr an den dramatischen verlauf in westafrika
Wo er, mehr als 11.000 menschen starben wir
Hatten ja ja das schreckenszenario von super verbreitern beschreibung genau das scheint jetzt geschehen
Zu sein die neuigkeiten aus dem kongo jetzt per klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Ebola ist ein fieber das in rund der hälfte der fälle zum tod
führt es beginnt relativ harmlos wie eine grippe aber im weiteren verlauf fangen die opfer überall an zu bluten und sterben schließlich an
multiplem organversagen
Übertragen die krankheit meistens von sogenannten reservoir würden das sind wildtiere die gejagt
Und gegessen werden durch die abholzung von wäldern rücken menschen immer näher an diese populationen. Heran
und jagen dann flughunde affen oder zum beispiel
Stachelschweine dieses buschfleisch, führt. Dann meistens zum. Ausbruch der seuche im kongo ist das jetzt geschehen, wir. Hatten ja darüber berichtet
Und wir hatten auch. Noch mal. Beschrieben was sie solche in westafrika. So unkontrollierbar gemacht hatte super verbreiter
Hatten die solche an große personen gruppen verteilt die sie. Dann
weiterverbreitet hatten ein anders war zum beispiel der tod einer heilerin die
Dann, von hunderten menschen bei ihrer trauerfeier rituell gewaschen wurde sie, alle hatten sich
Dann, angesteckt und die solche verbreitet. Und genau das scheint jetzt auch
Im kongo passiert zu sein doch die folgen könnten hier dramatischer sein des ebola bereits
Und das war damals nicht der fall in einer millionenstadt in dem band aka aufgetreten da kam es jetzt, zu einer dramatischen situation
So klemm klammer dollar 2 hat seine grenzen schilderte die flucht von drei
Patienten aus einer station im bann dakar zitat die patienten befanden sich in der aktiven phase der krankheit
Und erbrachen so der arzt laut der washington post ihre familien. Holten sie aus dem krankenhaus
Legten sie auf motorräder und nahmen sie
Zu einem religiösen treffen von 50 personen mit ebola ist durch körperflüssigkeiten anstecken
Und beide patienten die sich in einer. Akuten phase der krankheit befanden starben innerhalb weniger
Stunden danach damit ist der worst case eingetreten sie
Und das waren insgesamt drei sogar dürften dutzende menschen angesteckt haben und dass eben in einer millionenstadt zitat in allen drei fällen
wurde von den, krankenhausmitarbeitern alles unternommen, um die patienten
Und ihre familien davon zu überzeugen ihre behandlung nicht zu verlassen was erklärt
Barrieren brust sagt eine pressesprecherin von ärzte. Ohne grenzen
Zitat es ist bedauerlich aber nicht unerwartet
das sagte tarik, jasarevic sprecher der weltgesundheitsorganisation
Who?
Zitat es ist normal dass menschen wollen dass die. Lieben zu den letzten lebensmomente zu hause die ärzte. März sehen
So wie jetzt fieberhaft nach allen kontaktpersonen
um sie möglichst schnell zu isolieren aber dieses ereignis könnte ist jetzt deutlich erschwert haben die solche zu
Kontrollieren wir hatten ja schon geschildert das ist außenbahn dakar erheblichen güter. Und personenverkehr in die hauptstadt. Kinshasa gibt
Und man da kam mit rund 1,2 millionen einwohnern bietet dabei den. Idealen. Nährboden
Um, eine solche schnell zu verbreiten es gibt kaum elektrizität
Und noch immer nur wenig sauberes wasser die menschen die mobil. Und können den erreger innerhalb von nur wenigen stunden
Anders als im ländlichen raum im ganzen
Kongo verbreiten kommt die solche dann in kinshasa an dann ist viel schneller mit einer
Internationalen verbreitung zu rechnen als es noch in westafrika der fall war im gegensatz zum ausbruch
2014 ist die weltgesundheitsorganisation
dieses, mal aber deutlich besser vorbereitet
Ein experimenteller impfstoff wir hatten ja die repariert berichtet ist dort bereits. Im einsatz und es wurde bereits mit der impfung von
628 kontaktpersonen also
Pflegepersonal und ärzten und ärzte begonnen ich hatte euch versprochen. Euch auf dem laufenden. Zu halten diese nachricht die zum, beispiel
Noch nicht in etablierten medien. Zu finden das mache ich auch weiterhin, er wisse ja dass das abo modell auf youtube nicht
So richtig funktioniert deshalb wenn, er also nicht zum. Ausbruch verpassen wollt und als erste informiert werden wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer
bei whatsapp und den anderen messengern dann erfahrt
Ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich und garantiert einfach hier draufklicken
Und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks, um, social media abonnieren der vater als neuestes aus der social media welt das
Aktuelle zum beispiel jetzt die anhörung von mark zuckerberg vor dem europäischen parlament aber nicht die
genau, glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit
Dafür auch draufklicken neuer ebola. Ausbruch die vorgeschichte des ausbruchs definierter da ansonsten bis. Dann
bleibt dran